so
right into that hip pocket
and then pressure has to come from this
vector otherwise you don't have a pin so
here i have like a joint manipulation
but he can slide out to his
uh right go see
so you have to move in a way that the
vector is going
this way and that's with this step here
then you have a pin
right into place and you see it's going
this way
okay
[Music]
okay so he counters it here take this
opening here
boom thumb leads kind of reverse naked
you'll hit empty space come back
backwards
so
[Music]
okay so uh she she's letting go at the
bottom
and she's dropping her elbow inside okay
so people do that but that opens up
cordovech
she opens up on the bottom like that
[Music]
you'll just follow the in space you see
if i keep
pushing it's going to cut off you see it
comes around
boom
it's going to cut off
and you just add your movement
okay so he drops underneath my technique
right
we're going to do a joint manipulation
on his on his head so i'm not turning
his head
there is a kind of you feel how that
tightens there so here
it's going to turn him but i'm going to
tighten it right in there then that's
myself
in there it's locked now now
okay hey